nous sommes le 7 septembre 2016 nouvelle
édition du 7 8 elle les invités
aujourd'hui il sera question de
politique notamment en déplacement dans
les yvelines nicolas sarkozy a reçu un
soutien de poids député président et les
républicains dans le département david
douillet a balayé les accusations qui
visent l'ancien président dans la sphère
bygmalion vous l'entendrez religion
également ce soir bientôt un temple
mormon dans les yvelines au chesnay plus
précisément ce sera une première en
france rencontre avec le porte parole de
l'église mormone qui nous en dira plus
sur l'avancée des travaux et puis
religion toujours le conseil des
institutions musulmanes des yvelines
vient de fêter sa première année à
d'existence comment l'institution réagit
à l'actualité de ces derniers mois
attentat à burqini création également
d'une fondation pour l'islam de france
le secrétaire général du conseil des
institutions musulmanes des yvelines est
en plateau avec nous bonsoir à vous
abdelaziz al jawhari bonsoir c'est
d'être bien sur ce plateau s'il est ravi
le simi qui fait donc son premier
anniversaire on va revenir sur cette
action que vous menez dans le
département mais tout d'abord par
rapport à l'actualité et la volonté du
gouvernement de créer cette fondation
pour l'islam de france son président
c'est jean pierre raffarin jean pierre
chevènement excusez moi ça aurait perdu
son père à fin mai c'est jean pierre
chevènement ce serait mieux est ce que
c'est une bonne idée ce conseil a en
fait déjà dans un premier temps vu le
calme plat dans lesquels on était dans
l'organisation du script de france de
manière générale pendant toutes ces
années le fait qu'il y ait une dynamique
c'est déjà une bonne chose maintenant le
diable est toujours dans le détail
cependant qu'on peut avoir des
divergences ou deux points de vue sur
tel ou tel poids mais en tout cas la
dynamique elle est allée intéressante
donc maintenant on attend les contours
très précis donc fin août on était
plutôt partie sur une fondation autour
de la question des lieux de culte et
donc le projet a changé complètement de
nature donc est ce que là on est
complète on est plutôt sur quelque chose
plutôt de culturelle et la question de
culture lui-même je pense que la
question reste encore entièrement posée
on parle d'islam de france avec cette
fondation il existe un islam de france
en islam en france selon l'appellation
même d' islam de france en fait je
comprends bien le débat mais il ya une
chose aller sûr il ya des français
musulmans donc voilà ça on peut pas
diverger dessus et comment dire cette
partie de la population à des besoins en
termes d'organisation du culte et donc à
partir de là
voilà ça nécessite un certain nombre
d'actions c'est si toute une
organisation vous êtes en charge du
secrétaire de cette institution
musulmane dans le département des
yvelines il ya cette fondation qui voit
le jour également on a l'impression que
les les fondations les institutions se
multiplient on empile un petit peu les
structures est ce que tout ça sert à
quelque chose oui ça sert donc c'est
vrai que bon il faut aussi avoir un peu
de recul parce que
la question de l'islam l'organisation de
l'islam en france c'est un dossier qui
date depuis plusieurs décennies donc
qu'est le cfcm qui a été mis en place et
après 13 ans c'est vrai que ça semble
long mais au moins aujourd'hui une
institution niveau national parce que le
pouvoir public elles ont besoin tout
simplement d'interlocuteurs et nous
notre marque et notre initiative au
niveau des yvelines c'est qu'on est
convaincu
que le souci qui avait c'est que vous
avez un très grand écart entre les
chaînes nationales et les chaînes
locales étant sur le terrain exactement
et donc il fallait tout simplement des
strates intermédiaire ça veut pas dire
forcément on n'est pas du tout dans la
thèse forcément de discréditer ou
complètement le cfc mode même si on peut
avoir des remarques sur le
fonctionnement sur le
comment dire la composition yacht mais
en tout cas il était nécessaire d'avoir
des strates intermédiaire est pour nous
la l'échelle départementale et la bonne
échelle parce que vous avez tous les
services de l'état et toutes les
administrations qui sont représentés et
c'est là qu'on vous avez des
associations locales qui vont discuter
avec le maire vous avez un tas de
questions qui sont liées au culte qui
sont pas du tout de la compétence du
maire ils sont de compétence au niveau
du préfet au niveau de l'éducation
nationale pour tout ce qui relève de
l'enseignement et insécurité donc c'est
pas des compétences locales et c'est pas
non plus une petite acs est sûre local
qui doit aller au niveau national pour
aller discuter voilà c'est pour mieux
répartir les rôles en quelque sorte et
et justement c'est cette action que vous
menez concrètement sur le terrain
l'actualité de service ces derniers mois
étaient difficiles il ya eu pendant
l'été ces attentats que ce soit à nice
et puis saint-etienne du rouvray aussi
non loin du département des aides des
yvelines quel est votre rôle justement
dans ces moments vis-à-vis de la
communauté musulmane et à l'extérieur
aussi parce qu'il est important de
communiquer vous avez publié plusieurs
communiqués d'ailleurs tant dans l'air
en fait au-delà même des communistes et
donc on a publié des communiqués ou non
organiser une marche
sur sur nantes la jolie au moment de
l'assassinât des deux policiers donc
notre rôle et il est de nature
premièrement c'est
comment dire prendre la parole au nom de
la communauté musulmane qui est
justement exacerbée parce que tout ce
qui se déroule on sent non parce qu'elle
ne partage pas du tout cette idéologie
puis tous et des choses qui sont
extrêmement emporté et deuxièmement
c'est au lieu que ces événements
dramatiques
contrairement aux objectifs de l'auteur
amène à des fissures dans la société au
contraire c'est insisté pour établir
encore et renforcer les liens avec les
autres communautés religieuses mais avec
toute la communauté nationale parce que
au delà de nos communautés diverses et
variées la première communauté auquel on
doit prêter tous attention c'est d'abord
la communauté nationale quel bilan vous
faites de votre action depuis un peu
plus d'un an maintenant la structure a
été lancé par le préfet notamment oui
donc la structure reste encore très
jeune donc une année c'est pas beaucoup
donc on a essentiellement travaillé avec
les institutions musulmanes au niveau du
département porte déjà réfléchir c'est
une structure une organisation mais où
nous avons travaillé aussi avec les
institutions publiques avec la
préfecture avec l'éducation nationale
avec l'union des maires des yvelines
avec un certain nombre d'institutions
publiques justement pour
comment dire dans notre pour que notre
expertise soit la plus fine donc
recueillir l'ensemble
comment dire des attentes et des
interrogations des uns et des autres
pour qu'on puisse avoir une action
beaucoup plus
comment dire
pérenne au sein du département au delà
de la problématique du terrorisme
notamment qu' aucune forcément
l'actualité il ya aussi des polémiques
qui surgissent régulièrement dernier en
date c'est celle du burkini par exemple
comment vous vivez ces instants là et
comment vous analysé par exemple ces
polémiques là on approche des échéances
électorales aussi on imagine qu'elles
vont se multiplier les déclarations des
candidats dans sont multipliés aussi
c'est vraiment dommageable parce que bon
je pense que l'actualité du pays sur le
plan social économique l'actualité
internationale et des sujets beaucoup
plus importants et beaucoup plus grave
sur lesquels il faut se pencher et
d'avoir des hommes et des femmes
politiques pour des visées vraiment à
très court terme alimenter des
polémiques
parce que croire que le burqini
aujourd'hui c'est la problématique de la
société française je pense que ça ça ne
convainc personne ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il ya des vraies problématiques ou
des vraies discussions sur la question
de la laïcité sur le comment dire
l'organisation du culte qui à 7,8 mais
vaut mieux se pencher sur les vraies
problématiques et sortir le débat le
débat de l'islam des polémiques des
petites phrases et est comment dire et
cette course un peu malsaine il va y
avoir cette course qui va s'amplifier
avec les élections récemment outreau
prochainement vous à talons c'est notre
crainte bon on espère que nos hommes et
nos femmes politiques prendront un peu
de hauteur et et voilà on voit tout le
pays qui râlent vous avez les
agriculteurs les chômeurs les les
employés et à six de suite donc je pense
qu'il ya des vraies problématiques qui
mérite beaucoup plus d'attention dans le
débat public merci d'être venu sur ce
plateau merci à vous pour cette séquence
du 7-8 les invités je rappelle que vous
êtes le secrétaire général du conseil
des institutions musulmanes des yvelines
merci nous continuons à parler de
religion avec l'inauguration prochaine
d'un temple mormon dans les yvelines au
chesnay ce sera une première en france
lancée en 2013 le chantier est sur le
point de se terminer et écoutez
dominique hamel ça c'est le porte parole
de l'église mormone et c'est au micro de
camille lambert les travaux aujourd'hui
avance selon le planning qui était prévu
on avait pris un peu de retard au début
parce qu'il a fallu dé polluer le sol
mais aujourd'hui tout est complètement
conforme au planning donc on est dans la
nuit qu'est ce qu'il reste encore à
faire il reste beaucoup de choses à
faire dans les jardins à l'intérieur que
vous ne pouvez pas voir malheureusement
mais il ya encore et il y as pardon
encore beaucoup de choses à faire à
l'intérieur du bâtiment à l'inter du
bâtiment est extrêmement peu développée
il ya tout à faire à l'intérieur du
bâtiment en général on s'adapte à
l'architecturé locale et à l'
architecture du pays à vous allez me
dire que ce bâtiment ressemble pas tout
à fait à une église traditionnelle
catholique mais il s'en inspire malgré
tout et l'idée de ne pas choquer et de
rester complètement dans le décor du
quartier le quartier a été vraiment le
quartier qui nous convenait on a vu
énormément de terrain ça fait plusieurs
années que l'on cherche et ce terrain
nous a vraiment convenu là le calme de
ce quartier nous convenait tout à fait
pour un lieu qui est un lieu de prière
les fidèles sont impatients de voir ce
nouveau temple à l'effigié des fidèles
sont très impatients d'avoir ce nouveau
temps puisque ce temple valeur éviter de
faire des milliers de kilomètres les
parisiens vont soit à londres soit à
francfort soit à berne en suisse donc il
faut 1200 km aller retour dont ils sont
impatients de pouvoir ne pu les faire et
puis il ya tous les gens qui sont
handicapés malades et et qui vont
pouvoir aller autant de ce qu'ils ne
peuvent plus faire maintenant en allant
à francfort on parle également de la
venue de nombreuses personnalités pour
l'inauguration avec notamment le nom de
mitt romney vous confirmez il sera là je
ne confirme pas la présence de mitt
romney parce que étant un fan
supervisant les les les invitations
j'avoue que j'ai pas encore mitt romney
dans ma liste un truc que je ne confirme
pas du tout mitt romney mais on peut
penser qu'il va y avoir des
personnalités on invite d'abord tout le
monde toutes les personnalités
françaises à venir à ces portes ouvertes
politique mais pas simplement politique
dans tous les domaines de la société et
puis il y aura peut-être mitt romney
pourquoi pas il est il parle un peu
français il aime le français l'a
rencontré il ya quelques années donc
pourquoi pas mais de toute façon ce ne
sera pas la vedette de cette
inauguration c'est un bâtiment religieux
et ce sont les autorités religieuses qui
resteront les premiers les premiers
visiteurs et les plus importants pour
l'inauguration inauguration ce sera elle
sera quand à l'inauguration sera en 2017
en 2017 on va peut-être apporter une
petite précision et on va dire dans le
premier semestre 2010 est voilà un tout
autre sujet à présent politique alors
que le parquet de paris vient de
requérir vous le savez le renvoi en
correctionnelle de nicolas sarkozy dans
le cadre de la sphère bygmalion l'ancien
président était en ce début de semaine
dans le département des yvelines
déplacement sur le thème de l'éducation
il a reçu le soutien de ses fidèles dans
le département à commencer par david
douillet député de la 12e
circonscription c'est le patron
également des républicains des yvelines
et c'est aussi l'un des conseillers
pendant cette campagne de la primaire de
nicolas sarkozy écoute et justement
david douillet à propos des affaires
judiciaires à une interview menée par
nicolas qui
nicolas sarkozy a une actualité qu'on
connaît quand vous voyez ce soutien là
quel est votre avis vous pensez que les
gens font complètement abstraction est
ce que vous pensez à contrario que ça
peut lui nuire quand même quelque part
vous savez les gens font la part des
choses voilà faut arrêter de penser que
les gens ne sont pas capables de voir ne
soit pas capable de voir les les énormes
ficelles les câbles que tendent
la majorité actuelle pour entraver la
route d'un homme vers la présidence vous
pensez qu'on est dans une forme de pas
de complot mais presque
les hasards font bien les choses je
dirais je vous laisse je laisse les gens
seuls juges quand on voit la nature
des faits c'est fin c'est cheap quoi et
les gens je pense ou sur l'enduit
conquis tout cas la preuve que c'était
pile quoique il s'agit de manipulation
politique grossière
qui devrait pas être
s'immiscer dans ce débat ne sait pas que
le problème c'est l'avenir de la france
quand c'est sérieux quoi la politique
politicarde de bas niveau ou de
boutiques noir sombre occultes dont tout
le monde parle c'est fini ce temps là
quoi voilà c'est faut arrêter ça quoi
place aux idées place au fond place à
ceux qui ont énergie place à ceux qui en
ont les capacités place à ceux qui ont
l'expérience et pour moi il s'agit de
nicolas sarkozy ni plus ni moins et
c'est la fin de ce nouveau numéro du 7-8
les invités rendez vous chaque soir vous
le savez dorénavant du lundi au jeudi
pour une nouvelle édition replays est
disponible sur notre site internet les
programmes se poursuivre
oh